patrick bruel qui a fait le buzz sur
internet avec une une photo cage
gentiment était moqué par les twittos et
réutilisées par les internautes on
appelle ça chez legends un même wagon
mais j'ai mis un quart d'heure il
m'expliquer ce que c'était soyez pas ce
que c'était carrément quand même nom
elle savait pas
[Rires]
la photo je vous la montre bien sûr
c'est patrick bruel lunettes de soleil
vous avez écouteurs dans les oreilles
la moue boudeuse pokerface au coeur un
wc il est évidemment en train de faire
un championnat de poker parce que c'est
un immense joueur de poker et donc lundi
elle est apparue cette cette photo et il
a passé la journée mais en top tweets
mais grâce à pleins pleins détournement
peut-être la photo est folle ouais on
est très concentrés et les internautes
ont beaucoup d'imagination bien sûr on a
été voir un petit peu ce que ça donnait
regardez alors on a on a droit
montrez moi ce qui ce qui s'est fait
comme détournement emprunter un style
aux quatre couleurs en disant je te le
rend jeudi
on a également patrick bruel caen lundi
matin son manager va lui expliquer qu'il
ait soudainement devenu un mème
qu'est-ce qu'on a encore les amis on a
quand patrick écoute ses propres
chansons beaucoup rire ou encore un
petit dernier un petit dernier faire
tailler à ta meuf la moitié du loyer en
lui faisant croire que tu payes l'autre
moitié
[Rires]
ils sont comme vous êtes très bon
et tous les twittos franchement il ya
des détournements à chaque fois super
sympa vous avez eu des photos de vous
même ou dans des émissions un peu
détournée ou pas les uns et les autres
mois déjà mis à part ma mère personne ne
connaît donc nous j'ai découvert à jouer
j'étais enregistre sur instagram je n'ai
pas compris pourquoi la danse aiguë des
haltes et je me marrais pour changer je
suis redécollage et fred semestre à
l'argile faux pas expliquez-nous comment
s'est sérieusement me laver ou pas ceva
d'arc à obala on traite les délires du
vocabulaire aussi vous savez c'est des
images gif animé sa façon je vous dis la
vérité
d'accord d'accord dans le même on sait
c'est une photo qui est vraiment prise
des tournées je suis appelé pour me
demander ce que ça voulait dire et alors
évidemment patrick bruel a répondu ça
c'est drôle et c'est très bien c'est
très droit moi quand je suis le dernier
à m'apercevoir que je suis un même
beaucoup d'humour quand même